okay let's count it out product number
one the new iphone se and number two
this is the new even more amazing ipad
air and finally number three this is mac
studio and studio display
i think i counted correctly on tuesday
apple held a pretty jam-packed
infomercial i mean media event
and naturally they announced that all
their products were incredible
incredible unincredible incredible
incredible groundbreaking incredible
creative it's incredible new chip okay
okay let me set some expectations here
most of these new products are
incremental updates to older products
except for the mac studio a crazy new
desktop let's break it all down number
one the iphone se here it is the brand
new 429 dollar iphone se
just joking this is the model from two
years ago but they look exactly the same
so what's the big new update here a15
bionic chip a15 bionic a15 and a15 a15
a15 yes there was a lot of talk about
the processor which is the same as the
one in the iphone 13 models apple said
this will enable better performance and
better battery life which is something
you'll need with the addition of 5g to
our most affordable iphone the new
cellular connectivity should make
downloading videos and files faster that
is if you're in a 5g coverage area and
you need to download seven seasons of
true blood in record time because
emergencies happen really 5g is not a
reason to upgrade the reason to get the
sv is that it still has a home button
and it's the most affordable iphone now
at 429 though up from 399
the sc has a single 12 megapixel camera
but the processor unlocks better photos
and features such as smart hdr4 deep
fusion and portrait mode you'll need to
go up to the iphone 11 at 499 to get
face id and two cameras or you can just
go for the new green colored iphone wait
i mean sorry there's an alpine green for
the iphone 13 pro and a green green for
the iphone 13. because what better way
for apple to boost high-end iphone sales
mid-year than with the color of money
okay fine i like the new color
number two the ipad air just like the
iphone se the new ipad air looks like
the old ipad air
i bet you can guess what it's getting
ultra fast 5g to ipad air it also now
has a faster m1 processor plus it has
two 12 megapixel ultra wide cameras one
on the front and one on the back the
front one now supports center stage when
you're video calling the camera will pan
to you in frame and widen if someone
else jumps in that said apple still has
the ipad webcam positioned wrong for
horizontal video calling
just move the camera apple number three
the mac studio and studio display okay
here's the one i'm the most excited
about for those who haven't been paying
attention a few years ago apple said it
was going to transition its max from
intel chips to its own chips with our
first chip designed specifically for the
mac
and we call it
m1
m1 has been
all the new m1 chips have made macs
faster and cooler as in temperature now
apple's releasing m1 ultra it is a
monster of a chip and it brings
breathtaking levels of performance to
the mac desktop the new chip which is
really two m1 chips put together is
eight times faster than the m1 as this
apple executive said that's more than
four times the bandwidth of the leading
multi-chip interconnect technology and
this new mac studio is the first to get
this new powerful ultra chip which can
do all sorts of high performance tasks
mac studio can play an unprecedented 18
streams of 8k prores 422 video the
desktop looks bigger than the mac mini
and has room for all the ports you could
possibly want guys
two usb a ports in 2022
it's crazy and here's my real favorite
news of the day this crazy 27 inch 5k
studio display it has a built-in 12
megapixel camera with center stage which
should finally make video calling on a
mac as good as it is on an iphone but
since these are aimed at pros they're
not cheap the mac studio starts at
nine hundred and ninety nine dollars
with the m1 max chip and starts at three
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars with the m1 ultra chip the
studio display starts at one thousand
five hundred and ninety nine dollars
they will be available on march 18th it
was a lot to take in they started with
the most basic iphone at 429 and ended
with a four thousand dollar ultra mac
studio
so yeah consult your bank account and
get back to me with some questions and
to the person at apple whose job it is
to come up with all these superlatives i
just want to say amazing amazing
groundbreaking it's amazing and amazing
really amazing